got some breaking news Sky News has
learned that the chair of parliament's
party gate inquiry was in contact
personal contact with kirstan's incoming
Chief of Staff the infamous Sue gray
while she was still a civil servant
let's bring in Joe Pike so Joe what
exactly have you learned and how
significant could it be well there are
two individuals here wealth first of all
Harriet Harman the veteran labor MP who
chairs the Privileges committee inquiry
into Boris Johnson whether he
potentially misled Parliament around
party gate and also Sue gray the former
senior civil servant who of course
investigated what was happening behind
the scenes in the in the cabin office
you can see Sue gray here who a couple
of months ago Sky News broke broke the
story that kirstamp had recruited her to
be his chief of staff what we can reveal
today is that the two women were in
personal contact last year in the early
stages of Harriet Hammond's a
parliamentary inquiry now you may argue
why not one of them had investigated at
1 part of it this maybe animal wants to
learn lessons but there of course will
be people particularly particularly I
imagine sponsors of Boris Johnson who
would be maybe concerned about the fact
that two now or labor people were in
such close personal contact uh the quote
that we've used in the piece is I just
speak to sue Harriet Harman telling
colleagues I just speak to sue directly
on the phone I think not through
officials in Parliament or officials in
the civil service now we have had a
statement released in the last few
minutes from the Privileges committee
that Harriet Harman shares they said
this it was the duty of the chair to
make contact with anyone including Sue
gray who might be able to indicate
potential Witnesses the only evidence
the committee will rely on is that which
is separately and independently verified
by the relevant witness the Privileges
committee is not relying on evidence
gathered by Sue gray they also say that
the chair with the full knowledge of the
committee has had regular contact with a
number of ministers and officials in the
cabin office where degrees to work to
discuss matters such as the provision of
documents to the committee the identity
of potential Witnesses and the welfare
of civil servants who may have been
affected by this inquiry so potentially
some questions for both Sue gray and
Harriet Harman to answer I've contacted
both of them today no response as yet
it'll be interesting to see what what
conservatives make of all of this and
just to touch on this a little bit
further I mean clearly when an
investigation of this silk is is being
carried out you want to avoid even the
appearance of any conflicts of interest
so much so that Harry Harmon wasn't
originally going to be the chair of this
investigation and Chris Brown had to
step back from it so this sort of plays
into all of the debate around that sort
of it certainly does and we should also
say there is no evidence that Harriet
Harman was aware that KIA stammer was
trying to recruit Sue gray and there is
also no evidence that Sue gray was
speaking to Harriet Harman after she had
been approached by labor but as you say
it's sort of the appearance of conflicts
of interest as much as the sort of the
the evidence of it um some would argue
this is perfectly right that these two
individuals were speaking learning from
each other as I suppose we'll have
questions